there are bunkers everywhere in this
country
nevertheless their objective Remains The
Total Conquest
[Music]
I'm currently inside of the largest
bunker in all of Switzerland it is
massive I mean look at this place
thirty thousand square meters of space
which is 300 000 square feet for those
Imperial people out there like me and
I'm hanging out with Eric Who currently
owns the bunker this is where the crew
was taking the showers
showering 85 meters of rock above it
yeah it's got to be one of the deepest
showers in the world he's been showing
me giant cannons and the sleeping
quarters and the hospital and the giant
generators that have provided
electricity for this place
foreign
from the outside this thing does not
look big at all wow
look at that
that is amazing a reminder that every
time you see a little door in the forest
it goes into a bunker it's probably a
massive network of tunnels two meters of
concrete here at the entrance you go
inside of this door and you are let into
a Labyrinth of tunnels and weaponry
eight kilometers of walkways eight
kilometers yeah
oh and with the most gnarly doors you've
ever seen in your life they're quadruple
fortified with huge slabs of concrete
this is like two meters of concrete
it's sit behind there with a rifle and
be able to protect the entrances no one
is getting into this bunker anytime soon
[Music]
I went to Switzerland to hunt for
bunkers fortresses drilled impossibly
deep into mountains and cliffs and
Villages hidden from view but packing
deadly power wow I've seen so many
bunkers you don't have to look super
hard to find them they're everywhere but
there's a bunker right here look at this
this is not a rock this is a door
these little doors in the middle of the
forest so unassuming so benign but boy
if you knew what was inside let's be
clear this isn't normal most countries
don't bore into mountains as their
defense strategy but Switzerland isn't
like other countries when you live in
Switzerland you never really have a
sense of threat we're Switzerland we're
neutral rights and nothing gonna happen
to us
so instead of forming alliances and
sending troops they dug and the results
are nearly ten thousand of these
scattered all throughout the country and
that is what I've been searching for
okay okay okay where are you my bunkers
where are you my bunkers ah I see
something down there that is not natural
erosion on this Cliff I keep looking for
more and more and I'm realizing there
are too many for me to fly to like there
are dozens up there this Cliff is just
riddled with little Windows totally
primed and prepped to just light up this
entire Valley if there was an invading
Army from the north oh and it's not just
the mountains I also discovered hundreds
of thousands of bunkers dug under Swiss
homes a further expression of the Swiss
habit of digging to remain neutral the
bunkers are at the center of a
discussion that is heating up as the
world becomes dangerous again so
Switzerland is once again debating what
these bunkers mean to them and what it
means to be safe secure and neutral in a
changing world
[Music]
okay wait before we continue this story
I need to tell you about today's sponsor
as we look at the beautiful Swiss
Countryside today's sponsor is nordvpn
which is a long time supporter of this
Channel and I'm very grateful for that
I've been here in Switzerland traveling
and when I travel my computer and all of
my accounts kind of freak out because
they think I'm like someone logging into
all of my accounts from a different
country but it's really just me so what
I do is I click one button and I log on
to nordvpn and it connects me to the
internet via the United States so all of
my accounts work nicely this is like a
big deal if you've ever been in like the
death Loop of two-factor authentication
like can't send you a text message
because you're in a different country
anyway that is just one use case nordvpn
can be used for a million things not
only can you connect to the internet
like via the UK and like watch like
Netflix UK being connected to the
internet is becoming like a Minefield of
different threats whether it's like
fishing or your password getting stolen
or just like malicious trackers the
internet is not as safe as it used to be
I love this because it just operates in
the background it's one button you click
it it just does all the things and right
now they have a 30-day money-back
guarantee if you don't like it you can
get all your money back within 30 days
so go click the link in my description
it's nordvpn.com Johnny Harris clicking
that link helps support this channel but
it also gets you in on an exclusive deal
that is happening right now where you
get four months of nordvpn for free
thank you nordvpn for sponsoring this
video and making it possible for me to
come here and make this in-depth piece
on bunkers
it's like a dream come true okay
I'm gonna get back to the road
I'm on top of a mountain overlooking a
stunning view but I'm looking for a
bunker up here it's on the wall of this
Cliff I think I need to fly the Drone to
find it but it's raining that's a
problem the fog's rolling and I gotta be
quick
okay up on the side of this Cliff I know
there's a bunker nearby
oh God
[Music]
okay that was too close
all right I think this is my takeoff
point
oh yeah I see bunkers I see bunkers oh
homeboy just blending into the side of
this mountain oh my God look at this
[Music]
I mean just looking at these bunkers you
start to realize how incredibly
ambitious of a feat this is to drill
into the side of a cliff and decide to
build an entire network of tunnels that
are connected and well armed and
strategically placed so you can hit the
targets you want to hit oh look there's
another one oh my God look at this that
is just at the base of this Cliff oh my
goodness and it's hidden the only reason
I can see it is because I am above it
but if you're looking at it straight on
you don't see it it Blends in perfectly
look at that there's one behind all of
these little facades they're just guns
that are hiding in the wall of this
cliff
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay on to the next bunker
[Applause]
[Music]
Swiss we're really good at digging into
mountains building cable cars trains
they just they got really good and that
prowess for digging became incredibly
useful in the 1940s when their situation
looked like this
surrounded by fascist regimes that are
quickly taking over Europe very
effectively these two allies Italy and
Germany with Switzerland kind of
sandwiched right in the middle neutral
Switzerland wanted to stay out of the
war so they did whatever it took but one
of the major things they did when they
wanted to stay neutral was they started
digging
[Music]
they turned their mountains into a
literal giant Fortress Yes you heard me
right they turned their mountains into a
fortress or I guess technically if
you're a military nerd a readout readout
just means basically an impenetrable
Fortress that is dug into the ground but
readouts usually look like this one
Fortress Switzerland wanted to turn
their entire Alpine region which is like
a huge part of their country into a
giant readout I'm going to explain to
you the strategy in just a second like
what the thinking was here because it's
a little paradoxical and weird and war
is weird but yeah the point is here that
they started digging and digging and
started creating what one historian has
called the biggest Fortress in Europe
foreign
[Music]
I'm at the base of the Swiss Alps right
now and I'm in a village that is very
Switzerland it's got a lot of grass and
cows and barns but a few of these barns
like this one behind me have a little
secret inside
[Music]
wow
this gun is massive has a range of 21
kilometers and this is just one of four
Barn bunkers that are all connected to
each other in this Village
we're going down here
so now we're in the tunnels
oh my gosh wow
so we're just walking under the Green
Grass and the cows right now
[Music]
foreign
grenade
[Music]
you have to use this shell for
[Music]
explosions
and the whole thing works
like that oh it's like a giant bullet
yeah first grenading and then the
shelving
shows to the people that they have to be
quiet if they to to uh to protect all
our army Secrets normal people and the
social engage keep quiet yeah yeah all
top secret
Switzerland turning their country into a
giant Fortress was basically made
possible because of these giant natural
walls that they already have if you're
an invading Army you can't get a bunch
of men over these mountains but these
walls had gates in them those gates are
called mountain passes and when you're
not in Wartime mountain passes are
actually really good do you see that
bridge behind me that bridge has been
used for a long time to let people flow
throughout this pass but if you're
Switzerland in 1942 these gateways
through the Alps that have been used for
trade are now a liability they're now a
Gateway for invading armies to come take
over your country
so this is where they focus their
attention all these choke points all of
these gateways to their mountains the
idea was if the Italians start coming
from that way or the Germans start
coming from that way they can sit in
their bunkers and blow The Smithereens
out of anyone coming up this pass
because again it's a choke point no one
can go anywhere else you can't go over
the mountains you have to go through
this pass
all right I'm down from the mountains
for a little bit and it's because I got
invited to hang out with this guy he's a
retired Swiss historian who's freaking
obsessed with maps of Switzerland I've
never felt so seen in my life I'm an
artillery Gunner I did my basic training
in a fortress and then we went here just
for training Zurich in the pre-alps he's
showing me with this amazing 3D relief
map what this Fortress actually looked
like here in these high mountains where
several very very important
fortresses some here there were old ones
and some Modern new ones here here and
even even here here is there are bankers
and there is Toblerone do you understand
yes I saw the Toblerone
there is a last Toblerone and also here
is one when France was defeated in the
summer 1940 and so it was surrounded by
the axis this will say let's say an
emergency solution this was the redoubt
[Laughter]
okay so I hike up to this Swiss House in
the middle of the pass looks like just a
normal Swiss house is beautiful but you
look closely and you see something these
windows aren't real windows they're
painted on this thing is actually solid
concrete this is not a chalet these are
not like barn doors oh wait are they
gonna let me do this oh my God oh my God
those are just little gun holes put your
gun through that thing and you can shoot
foreign
this house is not just a house with some
gun holes in it it's actually a network
of tunnels
hey check this out I found a fake rock
with a gun in it I was looking at this
rock and it looked a little weird like a
little off up close it looks like like a
real Rock it's not with thunder
yep
oh yeah
boom I see your secrets have you looked
at enough bunkers to know what the
Playbook is hide something either in a
village or in a mountain put a huge
network of tunnels under it and just
point at the pass
and get ready to fire in case there's an
invasion
but wait a minute let's examine the
logic here yeah it's really cool to have
mountains full of really protective
bunkers really cool but most people in
Switzerland do not live in the mountains
most people live up here on this flat
plateau and in the early 1940s they were
sitting ducks the point here was not to
protect the people directly but rather
to signal to Hitler and Mussolini that
if they wanted to connect their two
empires they would have to go through
the Alps and that that would be
incredibly costly and basically
impossible it's like using defense as
the deterrent oh and it worked the Nazis
had a plan all fleshed out to invade
Switzerland but they never did it and
yes that is not just because of these
bunkers it is because Switzerland was
letting the Nazis store money and stolen
stuff in their Banks trading with them
Etc the bunkers were a part of the
deterrent strategy but the Swiss really
pandered to the Nazis as another form of
staying neutral something they hear a
lot about even you know 70 years later
I'm at a dam and if my Intel is right
that big giant mountain behind me is
actually a bunker
[Music]
I don't see anything
wait a minute yes I do what is that what
is that
I see you big boy you are a very well
hidden gun wow that thing Blends in very
nicely with that as their Fortress
like they can't no one can fire back
[Music]
another hidden bunker another successful
drone flight nice job drone
let's get out of here on to the next one
I hear there's a tunnel up up there at
the top of that mountain that foggy
foggy Wet Mountain
three and a half kilometers
I can do this let's go
[Music]
by the way big thanks to the subscriber
who
recommended this bunker to me I put a
call out to ask Swiss people what
bunkers I should go hunting for and this
is one of them
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah Hitler never invaded Switzerland
stayed neutral in the war but eventually
the Swiss government was like why are we
paying for a bunch of bunkers that we
designed for Hitler so they decided to
decommission them
a lot of them are totally abandoned
but then you have private buyers people
who have bought them to turn them into
whatever they want a lot of these are
museums or are owned by like military
organizations that want to preserve the
history but some people get really
creative with these bunkers like people
are growing mushrooms and fermenting
cheese in them or perhaps my favorite
use the place I slept last night
this is my hotel tonight
[Music]
I booked this hotel because I'm making a
story about bunkers and so I was like I
have to stay in the bunker Hotel I had
no idea
to be this
the full-blown deep deep the mountain
bunker there's dripping water everywhere
original ladders this place is nuts
okay well I'll get something
like dinner
it's bunker there's like a restaurant in
it and I go in there now
[Music]
[Music]
Switzerland is one of those beautiful
countries in the world this small
country surrounded by powerful Nations
has been able to remain neutral for the
past 150 years 150 years
and I'm back in the city and I need to
tell you the next part of the story
because
this is where it becomes relevant to
today the Swiss people have always been
ready to protect their country after the
bunker digging strategy worked in World
War II to keep Switzerland neutral they
kind of latched on to the idea digging
bunkers worked and they weren't gonna
stop doing it but the Nazi threat went
away and was replaced with a new threat
one that would not be deterred by
turning your mountains into a giant
Fortress
thank you
signal means to stop whatever you are
doing and get to the nearest safe place
fast it is called a cold war because
Armed Forces although use as a threat
are rarely Unleashed while the rest of
the world was busy making alliances and
arming themselves The Swiss turned to
their good old strategy of digging but
instead of focusing on the mountains
they turned to the city I've been
hanging out with Robin a Swiss
journalist who's been showing me around
the non-mountain version of Swiss
bunkers so this is like a normal
basement usually in a Swiss Swiss house
and then behind here
you mostly have this thick door it's
really nothing special it's just a
regular seller what we do as Swiss
people we store you know golf clubs we
we store skis wine but of course you
know with a special window with a
special filter so we close this
wow and then like this it's gotta be
funny that like American comes to town
and is like look at these bunkers and
you're just like no Johnny it's just a
seller it's a seller like there's
nothing special and I'm like but the
door is so thick so you're Switzerland
in the 1950s your big Alpine Fortress
digging bunkers thing worked and you're
like let's make everyone have a bunker
in their house so that we can be
protected against nuclear apocalypse
okay cool idea in theory in practice
incredibly impractical and very
expensive so they did what they do for
just about everything in Switzerland
they put it to a vote
and so in the 60s they decreed bunkers
as a right they actually lined out
exactly how to build bunkers they
required everyone to build them either
retroactively or in their new buildings
and the Swiss government would pay like
70 percent of the cost for these bunkers
the people would be protected using the
same strategy that they've always used
digging holes
so I went to the factory of a company
that makes bunkers the beds and the dry
toilets and the air ventilation I feel
like I'm wandering through the Ikea for
bomb shelters
and perhaps my favorite these giant
doors oh my God these giant doors I've
fallen in love with these doors I don't
know why they're just large they're
really fun to like push and pull and
they're just kind of cartoonish because
they're so freaking thick oh my God look
at that door
oh my God look at this thing oh yeah
wow there's nothing this is nothing
special no no oh and they always have
like this yellow wrench that have like
become very attached to like the yellow
wrench oh you see a yellow wrench and
like there's a bunker it's like safety
or something I don't know can I buy one
of these as a souvenir I've wanted one
forever oh oh my goodness I have a
yellow wrench I've always wanted one
thank you the bunker industry's been
slowing down since the end of the Cold
War for obvious reasons and it's no
longer required by the building code for
new houses to have a bunker but
unfortunately the Swiss bunker is now
getting a new wave of attention
[Music]
as the assault closes in on Kiev two and
a half million civilians are suddenly on
the front line Putin's invasion of
Ukraine is changing everything the fear
and the risk of having to use a bunker
like this is increasing it's crazy I
mean I mean the world started they've
got phone calls and emails daily
interestingly mainly from Germans 90 of
Germans who would call it was in
Switzerland we have 11 million more than
their people underground nuclear
shelters and Sherman is zero so I got
calls daily from people from Germany can
I rent a room here is
[Music]
people are thinking about their bunkers
again the government is inspecting them
making sure they have enough
I'm in a giant neighborhood bunker that
is for anyone on this neighborhood block
to come to in case of an emergency it's
fully decked out as expected and it even
has a full-blown operating room and a
room for dead bodies
think that's what that expected
Putin's invasion of Ukraine changed
everything for a lot of places in the
world but here in Switzerland it didn't
only change how people think about
bunkers and physical safety but it also
kicked off a debate about the complex
topic of Swiss neutrality the Swiss
government says it is adopting the EU
sanctions package on Russia that's a
huge move this is Switzerland who may I
remind you did not take a side when it
came to Hitler
was
President Ignacio Cassis said
extraordinary times called for
Extraordinary Measures joining in on
sanctions for a lot of people is a
massive violation of the thing that has
kept them neutral and peaceful for like
200 years
several parties saying well you know we
should be more flexible more traditional
parties saying well you know neutrality
means not doing anything not joining any
party not helping anything but rather
you know offer friedensburg I don't have
I don't know how you say
[Laughter]
[Music]
if you're from a country that isn't
obsessively neutral you're kind of like
dude you got to take a stance but here
they think differently about the right
side and the cost of choosing aside in
conflict or more importantly the benefit
of not choosing a side I think the
sweets are the people themselves want
neutrality yeah but you never know I
mean yeah the majority rules you know
democracy
[Music]
okay well that that's it that is my
journey I have to say this story left a
bit of an impression on me I came here
thinking I was gonna go hiking around
and stumble upon some abandoned bunkers
in the forest but as I dug into this I
found myself understanding Switzerland
in a new way this place where the people
didn't colonize other countries but
stayed here digging in their mountains
so obsessively to defend their ideas
about neutrality a neutrality that is
finding new meaning in a changing world
oh thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
hey so I filmed so much more than was
put into this video boy the work has
just begun it's kind of scaring me right
now it's old it's kind of broken it's
not as good and
I used to hear a lot about the American
is what it takes to get a bunker oh
okay I gotta go find that drone
like it's almost a travesty so much so
that I'm finally done not doing behind
the scenes I'm gonna start putting a
bunch of BTS up on patreon patreon is a
place that I turn to for support in a
world where I'm trying to do deeper more
factually correct journalism that is
expensive and time consuming so over on
patreon I'm gonna start to publish
behind the scene Vlogs or show you how
all this stuff is made I'm also going to
publish a full version of this tour that
I did through Eric's bunker it's way
longer and way cooler than like the two
seconds I was able to put in this video
and going forward I will be doing behind
the scenes stuff from the studio and
from my other travels so you can see how
this is made you've been asking for it
for a long time I've been resisting for
some reason I'm done resisting go become
a patron and help support independent
journalism if you want to support in
other ways there's Luts and presets that
are in the description and thank you
Switzerland for another amazing trip
I'll see you soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]